I don't think anybody would have said
it's more than 50 years ago now when
Elizabeth the second came to the throne
that the monarchy would still be around
in the 21st century and in many ways be
more beloved and more popular than
politicians I mean we're going through a
particular stage at the moment in
Britain of distaste and cynicism about
our political system and a political
class and the corruption that's been
them unveiled there at every level and
suddenly this this simple woman
Elizabeth the second I mean living in
all the splendor of the Royal Palaces
but these don't belong to her and
actually costing us very little money
indeed you wouldn't have thought as I
say 50 years ago that she would become a
sort of icon for people oh good old yeah
good old Queen you can always trust her
every year they released their budgets
they don't release how much security
costs but the monarchy still costs us
all in England Britain less than a liter
of milk every year this is not every day
or every week it's less it's about 70 P
what's that that's about 60 70 cents
it's less than a pound
the monarchy costs and I think people
feel you know in this age in which you
know who would have thought that Britain
would still be fighting wars in the 21st
century that though the royal family are
very inspiring for the military element
of of of life and this woman has done it
by avoiding the tricks of celebrity and
by modesty and service and she likes a
gin and tonic but you know that's about
the worst vice anybody's been able to
discover about her
monarchies are only as good as people
doing the job I mean at the moment I am
in particular studying the Saudi
monarchy and their King Abdullah is
doing the job very well in the opinion
of most people trying to bring in reform
elizabeth ii in britain has also been a
monarch whose quiet example of hard work
has struck a chord with people but you
know if the british monarchy were to
produce another Edward the eighth and
that by that I'm referring to the king
who in 1935 1936 conducted a love affair
with mrs. Simpson an American divorcee
shocked Britain and abdicated and if he
hadn't abdicated he'd have been forced
to abdicate now if the molecule were to
produce someone else like that then I
can see Britain saying well you know
let's get rid of it
in fact the Queen's heir the next in
line is this curious rather wonderful
figure of Prince Charles you know famous
for producing chocolate biscuits and
campaigning I mean this was a man who
talked to his plants and got worried
about co2 in the atmosphere when every
other person of his generation was was
with driving sports cars and smoking
cigarettes and he seemed totally out of
keeping and out of sync and here's an
example of a different sort of royal he
got involved in scandals many people
felt he mistreated the glamourous Diana
Princess of Wales but that's now behind
him and you know as we as we speak this
is a man who's trying to raise
consciousness about the world's
rainforests trying to persuade the
developed countries to stop the
destruction of the of the rainforest and
is thoroughly plugged in in the age of
sixty-two all the concerns of people
much younger than him
you know in his way he is me he is
likely to keep the monarchy going and
poppy there having said that you know
the monarchy is part of the British
class system the monarchy is part of the
British past and the British nostalgia
for the past which holds us back so I'm
not saying it's an unmixed blessing but
I'm saying that it's managed to find and
emphasize that the positive side and
actually make a contribution to British
life and then to go just to go back to
this issue of the corruption people say
well thank God there's some people in
public life who are not you know who are
trying to keep to higher standards I
mean the monarchy is sort of like a
religion in the less and less people go
to church these days but you know people
will still go and share outside
Buckingham Palace and of course there's
the this year pageantry of it you know
the cynics would say Britain shouldn't
get rid of the monarchy because if we do
we lose our tourist trade who's going to
come and look at Buckingham I mean
people still go and look at the palaces
in France but they're not so much fun
without real royal people living in them
and the idea that when you look at
Buckingham Palace you can thing always
the Queen in there which is how when
there is she looking at at me that's all
part of them all part of the strange
mystique of the monarchy